There's one more useful aspect about declaring variables, namely comments. Have
a look at this variable declaration, we have a travelTime of 228 days. When you
read it you probably ask yourself, for which trip? Now I can tell you for which
trip, but when you write code it's very common that you look at your code
months or years later, or someone else looks at the code. And then they would
really like to know more of an explanation. In Java, we use comments to give
such an explanation. Notice, these 2 slashes, they are the comment marker.
Anything that's after the slashes is ignored by the compiler. It's just there
for humans. To understand the code. You can write anything at all after the
comment marks, and the compiler won't care. But o course, if you write nonsense
like this, the humans who read your code may hate you. Comments are for humans.
Use a comment whenever you need to explain something that might be difficult to
understand for the human reader.